What problems does material
design try to solve?
>> Well, the question of how
a user goes between all these
different devices is a key one.
And to the user, it's really just
they're doing this one task.
They're trying to do this one thing and
it doesn't matter so
much to them whether it happens to
be on the phone in their pocket, or
the laptop that's on their desk.
So we want that kind of continuity.
Something else we really
focus on is motion.
We've seen all too often that motion
is something that just kind of gets
tacked on at the end.
So you do all this other work, and then
you just kind of add in some animations.
>> After effect or something like that.
>> It is literally that, right?
It's all done, so
throw that thing in there.
We try to think about motion from
the very start, because we think that
kind of knowing how things
are going to move around is so
powerful for giving feedback to
the user about what they're doing.
So, you want to kind of plan for
that in advance.
And we try to have these materials that
give the material design it's name.
Or things like kind of paper and
ink that can kind of move in
predictable ways that feel tactile and
feel familiar to the user, but aren't
bound by kind of boring old reality.
It can do kind of these really
interesting things that makes
the user feel powerful,
and that's a key goal towards giving
them a satisfying experience.
>> So the inspiration comes
from design and material,
actual material getting to play with.
>> Yeah,
I mean we really wanted to look at
things that felt familiar to the user.
And we engage with those
materials every day.
We don't engage with, kind of,
these pieces of inscrutable glass.
>> That's right.
>> In our day to day lives except
when we're using these devices.
So why should that be the metaphor?
Let's go for something that's
a little bit more predictable.
>> So where do I as an entrepreneur come
to learn more about the material design?
>> The best place to start
is just Google.com/design.
So from that site,
we have a full specification,
a set of guidelines that
describes material design.
It breaks down the philosophy behind it,
gives you some key principles to employ.
It's richly illustrated with imagery,
with motion,
samples of video, and also has a lot
of resources that you can download.
So fonts, color palettes, sticker
sheets of kind of common components for
all of the typical design
tools that you might use.
>> So I can use those out of the box,
and not reinvent the wheel, right?
>> Exactly, and then it should be
very close to what you're getting on
the platforms that
directly support material.